to me the best shows are always when
when you're mixing it up and whether
that's having a conservative and a
liberal or having two conservatives who
disagree on an issue or whatever I don't
really care everything is more
interesting when there's disagreement hi
i'm anthony fisher for recent TV and
we're joined by andy levy the co-host of
the fox news late-night talk show redeye
a show that has featured many reasons
staffers on its panel including myself
and which recently received high praise
and the august pages of the new yorker
as a quote odd and often funny
late-night show that is not exactly
satire and not exactly anything else
either Andy thanks for joining us thanks
for having me did The New Yorker nail
the mission statement of red eye yeah I
don't I don't know that we have ever had
an actual mission statement but that's
kind of not bad actually because there's
times when we're satirical there's times
when we're serious the scientist famous
for cloning Dolly the sheep says we
should bring back the woolly mammoth
we'll take a fair and balanced look and
why why this could mean impeachment for
President Obama straight ahead a lot of
times it depends on the topic I think
there are some topics that lend
themselves more to satire or more to
straight comedy there are other topics
where you sort of got a lay down the
seriousness before you can even try to
satirize it on a good night I think we
have a really good balance and I think
that's what we sort of strive for red
eyes been described as kind of a
right-of-center version of The Daily
Show do you think that's accurate no
I've never thought that's accurate I
don't think any of us have ever thought
that's accurate we're a panel discussion
show it's just it's a different beast
III think to be any other version of The
Daily Show you'd have to be you have to
have a host who looks directly into the
camera and and and does his thing and
then maybe brings on guests one on one
but you can't you can't compare that to
the vibe of a panel show it's they're
just they're two completely different
beasts yeah I think I think more what
some people might be thinking though is
that it's for a right-of-center audience
that or there were at least that a
right-of-center audience could
appreciate it in and that even people of
all political persuasions can get into
you know the the anarchy that is read I
whereas you know other comedic shows
might be you know narrowcasting for a
liberal audience yeah
Part III would hope it's true that
anyone of any political bent could watch
redeye and think it's a fun show to
watch whether that's true or not I guess
you'd have to ask people of all those
political bends but there's definitely a
right-of-center ish mist to it well I'm
creating words here left and right I
mean I'm you know pretty libertarian
Greg went back when he was hosting was
libertarian conservative I guess you
would call him we have liberals on the
panel we have we have we have
libertarians on the panel who make me
look like Stalin
we have Stalinists on the panel that
make me look like I'm Rand so you know I
think what you try to do is you try to
bring a mix of people together and my
thing has always been I when you have a
panel discussion I want different points
of view and I meet it's boring if you
have four or five people sitting there
who are all saying variations on the
same theme to me the best shows are
always when when you're mixing it up and
whether that's having a conservative and
a liberal or having two conservatives
who disagree on an issue or whatever I
don't really care I just like it when
you know it everything is more
interesting when there's disagreement
whether it's like cold case if by case
you mean sores that aren't as contagious
as you might think so I surely would be
fine Greg Gutfeld you just mentioned you
know the original host who recently had
his name and the title of the show has
left the show but not left Fox he still
co-hosts the five and has a new weekend
show of his own are you all lost without
him what was he was the reaction of the
staff when they told you guys he was
moving on no I mean I obviously happy
for him proud of him that he's getting
to do all this stuff without Greg there
was no red eye
there was no me ever being on TV it's
not possible for me to overstate how
much i ôm how much the show owes him
because he was the show it's not gonna
be the same show and it can't be the
same show when it shouldn't be the same
show because the show Greg brought so
many unique things to the show that it
would be absolutely stupid to key
to do the exact same show with a
different host but hopefully we keep the
spirit and that sort of anarchic spirit
but channel it in a different way and
and ideally that's what will happen can
you talk a little bit about how you came
to be on the show how did you get to
know great yeah it was he at the time he
was blogging at the Huffington Post and
I was reading his blog and I did
something that I don't think I've ever
done in any other blog I was leaving
comments and my comments got sort of
more and more involved to the point
where he he kind of noticed them and he
emailed me and I thought oh this is cool
you know he emailed me he's like one of
my comments whatever and that's that and
so I emailed him back and and then he
emailed me back again and we started
sort of an email relationship and then
it got to the point where he would say I
just posted go over there and comment
and then a little later it got to here's
what I'm working on what do you think
you know and then from there it was he
was starting his own blog the daily gut
and he said to me he said I want you to
write with me so we started writing
together and not long after that I guess
Fox approached him about hosting some
goofy late-night talk show and he and I
had never met at this point he was
living in England because he was the
editor of maximum UK at the time and he
said I'm flying in New York I'm gonna
meet with Fox people we should get
together and so we got together had a
bunch of drinks and and from there it
just kind of you know Fox decided to
take a chance on this show with a bunch
of guys who had never been on TV before
and it just kind of went from there so
Wow so both you leaving comments and him
reading the comments to things that
probably you guys would never do now no
yeah
let's talk a little bit about how the
show has evolved you know obviously Bill
Schultz Schultz was on the show he used
to work the pinch puppet the pedantic
sleepy I had New York Times
correspondent picture I was at your
first acting for a well excellent use of
the crises of the word for I don't have
to say according to my writer I wanted
bottled water perhaps a rubdown and now
all-white green room I didn't get any of
those ah now Joanne no such in skis on
the show you were once the Ombudsman it
seems like a lot of things that were
huge fan favorites eventually you guys
just let him let him go and never look
back
what goes into that process a whole
bunch of things go into that process
part of it is we have gotten away from
the early goofiness and and the full-on
sort of anarchic spirit but part of that
is also just we got more professional
because we learned how to do our jobs we
didn't know what we were doing when we
started so we did goofy things and then
eventually you learn how to do something
the right way and then you stopped doing
it the wrong way and maybe you lose
something there but it's I think it's
also sort of a natural evolution you
can't do the same exact thing for eight
years for ten years for twenty years
without there being change it's just it
it doesn't work perhaps it's because
it's red eyes on a 3m and perhaps it's
because it's on Fox News but red eye
doesn't really have to deal with the
same kind of pressures about being
politically correct at the Daily Show or
other shows might you feel that that's
liberating as a performer or would you
even agree with that statement I'm not
sure I would agree with it okay we're
not in a spotlight the way The Daily
Show is we're not in a spotlight the way
primetime shows on Fox News are either
we're on at 3:00 a.m. so are there
things that we have said that would get
pounced on if people notice them I don't
know the answer to that honestly I think
we do a pretty good job of having done
this for eight years whatever we do a
pretty good job of knowing where the
line is for for us and the line is
different for everyone but have you ever
felt like you did a show or
there was someone on the show that went
too far for your tastes oh yeah
absolutely I don't it doesn't happen
often but it definitely happens you know
sometimes you just say well they said it
and you know sometimes you can get into
it with it like if a person says
something I can jump in or someone else
can jump in and say hey you know I don't
agree with that or whatever again having
a panel thing you almost can let more
stuff go because you can if there's a
reaction to that stuff then it becomes a
discussion and I to me that's preferable
to just saying you can't say that I
would a lot of times I would rather have
someone say that and then get into a
debate about whether that's a good thing
to say or a correct thing to say
or whatever it's sort of it's always
other people that determine whether or
not you've crossed the line I guess
maybe we can get away with more stuff
because we don't have as many other
people as something like The Daily Show
does but because it's it's up to them
like they would be the one saying you
know saying shame on you I can't judge
whether we've done anything that's
worthy of them saying shame on you so
you don't apologize for anything I
apologize for nothing great well thanks
so much for joining us with a co-host
Andy levy for Reason TV I'm Anthony
Fischer